the Targaryen blood of the Dragon in the
last of old Valyria were loved by their
subjects and admired far and wide as the
greatest dynasty in the history of the
Western world with the peace and
prosperity of nearly three centuries of
Targaryen rule was shattered by the
usurper Robert Baratheon and his band of
traitors House Baratheon owed its very
existence to the Targaryen was it not
Aegon the dragon himself who elevated
the bastard Oris Baratheon in the war of
conquest and what of the Starks the
Lannisters
the errands of the Vale all had been
spared and allowed to keep their lands
when Aegon could easily have wiped them
out centuries later the usurper and his
lackeys repaid Aegon's benevolence with
treachery there are some who dare to
claim Robert and his allies had reason
to rebel
they say the crown prince stole the
usurpers ladylove they say my father
King Aerys murdered Rickard stark and
his son without just cause whether these
charges are true or not it doesn't
matter the dragon answers to no one
Aerys his good name has been besmirched
in the years since the rebellion he's
been called a dangerous madman a monster
a tyrant that brought his tragic end
upon himself lies my father was a victim
of weaklings in his Council lackwits who
failed him in his hour of need and let
the rebellion spin out of control but it
was not enough
the Royal Army was crushed at the Battle
of the Trident it was there the valiant
Rhaegar met Robert in single combat but
the gods betrayed him and he perished by
the user of his hand as the field of
fire had marked the end of the end all
centuries before the Battle of the
Trident seemed to herald the end of the
Dragon kings when word reached the
capital of my brother Rhaegar death my
father Aerys moved to protect me as I
was the surviving heir to the throne he
sent me to the island fortress of
Dragonstone along with my mother Queen
rhaella who was great with child but as
my father my King Aerys Targaryen
prepared to defend his throne to the
bitter end little did he know of the
horrors and betrayals that awaited him
and our family